welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and marvel's one division trailer
broke records also
probably broke a few brains with its
channel flipping concept
i did my best to make sense of it and
how it's restructuring the mcu going
forward with things like x-men young
avengers witchcraft with a frame by
frame breakdown but there's one detail i
pointed out that comes right at the end
of the trailer that we
must go deeper into spoiler warning if
you want to go into wandavision blind
because curiosity kills the
schrodinger's cat i
feel like that makes sense if you were
to go into it but there's no time
because everyone's talking about the
deeper significance of the various
classic sitcom realities that wanda and
vision are flashing in and out of and
yeah those are probably important but
not as important as that little moment
the very end of the trailer in which a
woman in seventies attire johanna
paris's character
monica rambo adult version of the girl
in captain marvel future marvel hero
spectrum most likely
blasts out of the neighborhood that wand
and vision have settled in
propelled by wanda's red chaos magic out
through the tv screen membrane of this
pocket reality landing on the other side
of a military perimeter
i explained that this agency is likely
sword sentient world observation and
response department a new offshoot of
shield
normally their sights are set on the
stars which is why i think nick fury was
with sword and that far from home post
credits scene but in this case the
sentient world they're observing and
responding to is wanda's dream bubble
contained somewhere on earth
truman show style you're part of this
aren't you but the weirdest thing about
this moment that i pointed out
the sword agents themselves if you look
closely behind the arm dudes there's
darcy lewis
astrophysicists from the thor movies
cool but
slightly to the left there's monika
again
and yeah we know that she's a sword
agent from some set photos but there are
two monikas in the scene is this second
monika a devilish imposter and that's
why these agents are so jumpy
well my first instinct and a very likely
possibility is this
is yet another example of editing
trickery in trailers and promos
weird continuity errors like this happen
all the time as trailer editors
restructure shots and dialogue to
conceal spoilers and to create new
moments to try to sell this premise as
we saw with infinity war sometimes they
manufacture
shots that aren't at all in the movie
just for the trailer but investigating
this further
here's what's weird about this case what
benefit would a trailer editor be hoping
to achieve
by splicing these two shots together
like i get it there could be
another nighttime exterior perimeter
shot with monica and the sword agents
from a totally different scene
but why go to the trouble of splicing
that in like there's no great reaction
to gain from this frame that we don't
already have from the wide overhead shot
showing the armed agents in the
helicopter spotlight and looking closely
at that overhead shot you don't
see that front agent or darcy or monica
but they could be in one of those cars
or trucks that are
in the process of pulling up and in the
close-up of monica's face when her eyes
are opening you can see those trucks
approaching in the distance and that
helicopter searchlight so the continuity
does match
up here aside from that double monika
either way
yeah i could see this all being part of
the same scene really i think monica's
expression is the most telling piece of
evidence we have
her eyes flutter a bit and then they
open wide unconcerned calm
this is not the face of someone who is
just suddenly super smashed out of a
brady bunch cosplay
monica looks like she is exactly where
she wants to be
and that's why i think there is
something to this idea that this version
of monica
could be an imposter in disguise as
monica
not a scroll shapeshifter well maybe
actually i should come back to that but
we should first consider that monica 2
could actually be a disguise worn by
methysto
now yes you might be thinking why does
this dude keep bringing up mephisto
there have been literally zero mephisto
sightings anywhere in the swan division
footage well in the language of our new
favorite house of m
wine bottle label au contraire just as
the greatest trick the devil ever pulled
was convincing the world that kevin
spacey was a good guy evil incarnate
takes many forms my friends
pennywise and it was a shape-shifter
bible stories and myths have depicted
the devil as a pig
a goat elizabeth hurley in this case i
believe marvel's devil
mephisto as he is in the comics that
want to vision is probably partly based
on
is deeply involved in a plot to
manipulate wanda with
illusions of her children and he is
hiding in
plain sight elsewhere in this trailer
level before i continue i want to thank
our friends ed currant for sponsoring
this video current is the new way to
bank it's a mobile bank account that
comes with this visa debit card
that has no minimum balance no hidden
fees and
free overdraft up to 100 bucks i hate
these fees on credit cards they punish
you for being broke
i hate credit card fees worse than paul
rudd hates aging
and you know he hates it he'll violate
the laws of quantum physics in order to
avoid it
thanks dude but with current you can use
over 55 000 atms for free
earn points on purchases and redeem for
cash and deposit checks with the camera
on your phone so you don't need to go to
any physical banks and you know risk
getting stuck behind that 200 year old
man who decides today's the day to turn
in all of his rolls of pennies you can
send money for free using your current
and it works with apple pay google pay
cash app venmo
so you can use that fun eggplant emoji
when you pay your friend back they
always love it i don't know what it
means but they love it it takes two
minutes to sign up and the card ships
for free
get a current black premium card shipped
to you for free by clicking on the link
in the video description
so to understand where mephisto is
hiding in this one division trailer we
have to first try to understand
how wanda's pocket universe works in the
scarlet witch house of m story
another possible comics influence on one
division wanda warps
all of reality into else worlds to try
to give herself a happy family life but
here
wanda's reality warping appears to be
confined to this small town
at least a few acres maybe a square mile
which could be an actual housing
subdivision
or a rural clearing in a part of upstate
new york that looks a lot like georgia
because that's where they shoot
everything
within this pocket universe everyone in
it seems to be equally oblivious to its
true nature in some moments though in
other moments they find themselves
awakening from a kind of trance we see
this with wanda envision when their
dinner guests question them about their
backgrounds
and there's definitely a confusion with
vision as he tries to get a bird's eye
view of the town and when he taps
agatha's head
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are hmm agatha believed
vision to be dead
suggesting that like those kids in
midtown high school and far from home
she also comes from a post-in-game world
where vision is dead from outside the
pocket reality
intruding into it judging from vision's
confusion
i assume he also started as an outsider
but was brought into this reality
agatha's right vision is dead we all saw
it and we did actually go into a few
explanations for how he could have been
resurrected in another video be sure to
check it out it's a good one but notice
the
mind stone is back in his head here and
that should not be
possible thanos atomized the infinity
stones at the top of end game
where are the stones gone
reduced to atoms and the past version of
the mine stone that they used to defeat
him
was return back in time pretty much
everyone at marvel has made it clear
that they're
done with using the infinity stones as
plot points themselves and no matter
what hypothetical timelines in the
multiverse the mind stone could have
existed in
all those timelines either would have
ended with thanos getting the mind stone
at the cost of vision's life
or in that one thanos-less timeline that
we've talked about before the mind stone
could have lived on in vision's head but
without thanos he wouldn't have died
so yes impossible right well assuming
vision is an
outside body to this pocket reality that
has been warped into wanda's projected
fantasy the same way
agatha has been means some form of
vision must have been
brought into this reality from the
outside the outside where he's dead
perhaps vision's android corpse
recovered from wakanda brought
into this pocket universe by monica and
sword and then
warped by wanda's chaos magic to be
reanimated with the projection of the
mind stone in his head once more so i'm
thinking that's a process
outside entities intrude into wanda's
warped bubble
where she colors them as part of that
illusion monica rambo and sword perhaps
used vision's body in hopes to reign in
wanda's reality warping to contain it
from spreading all over the world
but other intruders like agatha have a
darker agenda
to trick wanda with the promise of
having children with vision
while hijacking wanda's chaos magic to
spill that chaos all over the outside
world
this is essentially what methisto aims
to do in the comics and
agava serves mephisto and i think we see
the start of that plot
in the trailer where did you two move
from how long have you been married and
why
don't you have children yet our story
i think what my wife means to say is
that we moved for move from where
married when damn it why oh arthur stop
it
stop it stop it stop it red malamad here
is playing
arthur deborah joe rupp plays his wife
they appear to be some neighbor couple
joining wanda in vision for dinner but
they are so damn pushy
the way arthur badgers wanda about
having kids
it's freaking terrifying satanic some
might say
yeah i believe arthur here is really a
shape-shifted form
of mephisto intensely pressuring wanda
to have children children that he can
use to distract and manipulate her
rupp's character i believe is an
incarnation of agatha
who is subservient to mephisto working
with him trying to
temper his more violent tendencies
mephisto comes from marvel's underworld
and perhaps it was agatha encouraging
wanda's deeper exploration of her inner
chaos magic
magic that was imbued in her as a baby
by an ancient demon
that opened this gateway into wanda's
pocket universe
for mephisto to sneak in through these
false forms
i think this evil duo will continue to
appear in new forms in each of wanda's
new warps
agatha becomes the kimmy gibbler to this
full house reality
maybe mephisto becomes a dummy with a
traffic cone hat until
eventually mephisto tricks wanda with a
form that
she will recognize as fictitious the
sword agent who escorted vision
into this pocket reality monica rambo in
this form wanda will
expel from this bubble back into the
real world where mephisto's plan will be
achieved because now he can walk the
earth freely
now would mephisto have counted on the
op source of his flesh mask being there
the moment he broke into the earth
dimension
doubtful but i'm eager to see what kind
of hellfire mephisto as monica
is about to drop on these sword agents
and yeah this squirrel question
sword does probably work with a lot of
skrulls but i'm thinking that could be
part of the confusion from the sword
agent says
mephisto rises to like waste to them
there
monica is that your scroll double or you
got a twin you never told us about
my soul's on fire discuss these
theories with me on new rockstar's
official discord server by becoming a
patron at patreon.com new rockstars and
again thanks to current for sponsoring
this episode you can get a current black
premium card shipped to you for free by
clicking the link in the video
description subscribe to new rockstars
hit that notification bell
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
new rockstars thank you for watching and
uh
i think the real truth of monica rambo
getting thrown
out of this neighborhood i'm just saying
america's suburbs exist for a reason
and we do see wanda change her husband's
flash into that of a pasty white dude so
uh
who's the real mepisto
[Music]
you